new police incidents roil the country as
riots break out again in minneapolis
corporate america activates against
everyday americans and the media promote
coveted panic porn i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
the bed and shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn why haven't you gotten a vpn
yet visit expressvpn.com
we'll get to all the news in just one
moment first quick reminder you're
spending way too much on your cell phone
bill like
way too much because your big cell phone
provider they're telling you that you
need unlimited talk unlimited text
unlimited data you don't need unlimited
data here's what you actually need
unlimited talk text six
gigs of data for 30 bucks a month 30
bucks a month i could save you hundreds
of dollars a year
my friends at puretalk usa are making
that happen for you that's right instead
of charging you obscene fees to pay for
their massive mainstream media campaigns
corporate campuses retail outlets across
the country pure talk passes the savings
directly onto you the average family
will save over 800
a year it's a lot of money switching is
really easy you can keep your phone keep
your number or get huge discounts on the
latest iphones
and androids again right now you get a
limited talk text six gigs of data for
30 bucks a month and if you go over on
the data they're not going to charge you
for it
from your cell phone style pound 250 say
ben
shapiro you will save 50 off your very
first month that is pound
two five zero say my name ben shapiro
and begin your journey with pure talk
usa that is pound 250 dial it on your
phone
and say my name ben shapiro you'll save
50 off your very first month save
hundreds of dollars
across the course of the year by
switching over to pure talk usa alrighty
so we begin today with a couple of
updates on policing
situations that surely are going to be
national stories because
anytime the police abuse a white person
that is not a national story if they
abuse a black person that is obviously a
national story because it plays into the
narrative that the police
are systemically racist the story from
today there are two stories that are
worth note
with worthy of note with regard to
policing today one appears to be
an awful police action and one we just
don't know yet the first one that
appears to be a bad police action is
this
situation with joe gutierrez in windsor
virginia according to the new york times
a police officer in virginia
who confronted a uniform black army
medic at gunpoint and doused him with
pepper spray during a traffic stop
in exchange captured on video has been
fired officials said on sunday the
officer joe gutierrez was terminated for
his role in the december 5th encounter
involving caron notario a second
lieutenant in the us army medical corps
the town of windsor virginia said in a
statement posted on its website
officials said an internal investigation
had determined that gutierrez's actions
were not consistent with department
policy they did not provide further
details on when gutierrez had been fired
body camera footage of the encounter has
drawn widespread attention and criticism
of gutierrez as well as another officer
who was involved in the traffic stop
both officers were sued on april 2nd in
u.s district court in norfolk by
lieutenant nozario who has accused the
officers of using excessive force and
violating his constitutional rights
the there was no lawyer listed for
gutierrez in court records earlier on
sunday
governor ralph northam of virginia a
democrat said on social media he'd
become
begun an outside review of the encounter
he said the incident in windsor is
disturbing
and angered me i'm directing the
virginia state police to conduct an
independent investigation our
commonwealth has done important work on
police reform
we must keep working to ensure
virginians are safe during interactions
with the police and that enforcement of
laws is fair and equitable remember that
time that ralph northam almost was
forced to resign because
way back when he dressed up in full-on
black face and or akk outfit remember
that time yeah he's still the governor
over there
the medic was driving to petersburg
virginia from a drill weekend the night
of december 5th when he saw police
lights flashing behind him according to
the new york times
according to the lawsuit and video
footage of the encounter lieutenant
nazario who is black and latino drove
about a mile to a gas station because
he'd been nervous about stopping on a
darkened road
get out of the car one officer can be
heard yelling as lieutenant nazario
remaining seated repeatedly asked why
he's been stopped and why the officers
have
drawn their guns he positions his empty
hands outside the window
i'm honestly afraid to get out of the
car nazario says yes as gutierrez you
should be
according to footage from his body
camera nazario was wearing his army
uniform at the time
he said i'm serving this country and
this is how i'm treated what's going on
and gutierrez says what's going on is
you're fixing to ride the lightning son
after he was sprayed and zarya began
crying and cursing the police did not
even arrest him and did not file charges
in a report from that night the officer
said they had pulled over nizario
because his suv didn't have any license
plates
nizara said he'd recently bought a chevy
tahoe and was waiting for license plates
temporary ones had been taped inside the
rear window and we're visible according
to the lawsuit so that one
appears to be just an awful case of
police excess
and the officer has been fired and so
presumably he will lose a lawsuit
if the evidence proves what the evidence
seems to show there the officer will be
punished
this of course will be treated as
another example of
tremendous police systemic racism
although again given the man's name joe
gutierrez i'm not sure that the man is
white
and that is not a typically white name
so it's it's a little bit harder to say
that it's white on black
racism if it was in fact for example
latino on black latino
racism but they will say that the system
is racist no matter the ethnicity of the
officer
in this particular case and meanwhile in
another case that is gaining
national attention there's a man who was
shot to death
in an encounter with police this time in
minneapolis again
there were riots last night as people
attempted to use this
as an excuse to go loot the local
walmart that is another thing that
happened
so it's uh it it seems to me that no
matter the outcome with the police
looting the local walmart is not the
solution as it turns out
this encounter is again in doubt because
we don't have all the details
so everybody heard that a black man had
been shot by the police and they
immediately rushed to the judgment that
the police had
shot the man unjustifiably we don't know
the answer to that
and you're seeing the media also play
this game where they take a sort of
random detail
from the arrest and then they use that
to characterize the whole arrest they do
this routinely in criminal encounters
where they want you to believe that
that that the encounter was truly about
the random thing and not about something
else
and so for example in the trayvon martin
george zimmerman case the the detail the
media really fixated on was that trayvon
martin was carrying skittles in iced tea
and this was supposedly indicative of
the entire case even though the actual
case was about
whether martin was on top of zimmerman
and beating him into the ground or
whether zimmerman was attacking martin
and all of that
and same thing happened with with
michael brown the idea was that michael
brown
the the entire detail of the case was
that he was he had some
five dollar cigarillos and this was
deeply indicative of the case
in in in some ways it it really has
nothing to do with the heart of the case
but this happens repeatedly whenever the
media cover
uh a major police or racist inter or or
supposedly racist interaction
okay same thing is happening right here
now the story in this brooklyn center
shooting
is an air freshener so i'll explain why
according to the minneapolis star
tribune
a brooklyn center police officer fatally
shot a man during a traffic stop sunday
afternoon
inflaming already raw tensions between
police and community members in the
midst of the derrick chauvin trial
relatives of dante wright 20 who is
black told a tense crowd gathered at the
scene in northern minneapolis suburbs
sunday afternoon
wright drove for a short distance after
he was shot crashed his car and died at
the scene
protesters later walked to the brooklyn
center police headquarters near north
67th avenue and north humboldt avenue
and were locked in a standoff with the
police in riot gear late on sunday night
officers repeatedly ordered the crowd of
about 500 to disperse as protesters
chanted right's name and climbed atop
the police headquarters sign by then
covered in graffiti
police had to use tear gas flashbangs
and rubber bullets on the crowd
national guard troops arrived just
before midnight as looters targeted the
brooklyn center walmart and nearby
shopping mall because of course
when somebody even if somebody's
unjustifiably shot by the police it
seems like the best
probably the best thing you can do you
just go hit up the nearby shopping mall
for a pair of shoes or something
several businesses around the walmart
were completely destroyed including the
foot locker
t-mobile and a new york men's clothing
store by
quick judgment if you use the
opportunity of a tragic encounter
between a a person and the police as an
opportunity to grab yourself a suit from
the new york men's clothing store
uh you're a garbage person looting is
not a proper response to bad things
happening between the police
and civilians looting was widespread
late sunday into early monday spilling
into north and south minneapolis
reports said that stores in uptown and
along lake street were also being looted
as well according to
brooklyn center mayor mike elliott he
issued a curfew order until 6 a.m
they closed all school buildings they
canceled all school activities this is
just what this community needs i'm sure
he said our entire community is filled
with grief following today's
officer-involved shooting of dante
wright
a 20-year-old young man our hearts are
with his family and all those in our
community impacted by this tragedy now
again there's an investigation ongoing
what are the actual details of this
particular encounter
so apparently the department of public
safety commissioner john harrington said
minneapolis will wake up to more
national guard station around the city
due to reports of looting in shots fired
during the standoff with police rocks
and other objects were thrown at law
enforcement brooklyn central police
department does have body cams
there's likely video after the shooting
police
say brooklyn central police said
officers pulled over another vehicle for
a traffic violation
shortly before 2pm in the 6300 block of
orchard avenue this is the actual story
that at 2 pm before all this happened
there was a traffic violation the driver
who had a warrant
got back into his vehicle as officers
were trying to take him into custody so
the reason he was pulled over is
supposedly because he had an air
freshener that was blocking his rearview
mirror or something
they ran the plates they didn't think
that the guy owned the car or something
they pulled him over
and the guy took off and there was an
outstanding warrant for him
an officer discharged weapons striking
the driver the vehicle then traveled
several blocks before crashing into
another vehicle officers and medical
personnel performed life-saving measures
the driver was pronounced dead at the
scene
a female passenger was taken to the
hospital with injuries that were not
life-threatening his family had said
earlier that the shooting occurred in
plymouth but it had not
the bureau of criminal apprehension will
conduct an independent investigation so
again we will know more about this
because there were body cameras and dash
cams that were on
during the incident and of course as i
say when it comes to these particular
incidents the media likes to fixate
on particular details so katie wright
the uh
the alleged victim's mother said all he
did was have air fresheners in the car
and they told him to get
out of the car well he also had an
outstanding warrant apparently
he got out of the car and his girlfriend
said they shot him he got back in the
car he drove away and crashed now he's
dead on the ground since 147.
nobody will tell us anything nobody will
talk to us i said please take my son
off the ground within hours of the
shooting a couple hundred people had
gathered
near the scene and and then this turned
into a riot so here's the bottom line we
don't have details in this particular
case but that's not stopping the rioting
they're sort of pre-emptive rioting
in in minneapolis over all of this okay
so that is the latest on the law
enforcement front
now all you can say in these particular
cases that you ought to wait for the
details to come out because the details
usually
clarify the situation rather than the
initial reports we've had too many
situations in which riots have broken
out in major american cities
on the basis of incomplete reports that
are put out either by the media or by
people near the scene
of an alleged crime so before the media
jump into this is yet another example of
police races and we probably should wait
for exactly what happened here in that
virginia case different story we have a
lot more evidence because we have an
actual body cam video
and consequences will attend all of that
as they should
okay meanwhile we have a large
issue in the united states that is
worthy of talking about and that is that
there's a huge swath of america that
believes they're engaged in the
quote-unquote resistance when they are
in fact the dominant
upper hand in american politics right
now these folks are not the resistance
they are the most powerful voices in our
society
and posing themselves as the resistance
allows them to get away with quashing
descent
i'm old enough to remember when the
democratic party suggested that
corporations should have no voice in
politics at all corporations were not
people
corporations were bad bad bad bad bad
this is why we needed campaign finance
reform because if you
owned a corporation and you gave money
from your llc
to some sort of of campaign this meant
that you were engaged in an attempt to
strip american democracy
of all of its plenitude it was an
attempt to get rid of the diversity of
american democracy using institutional
power now however the left has realized
that they ought to do with corporations
what they've done with nearly every
other institution in american society
and simply grasp the means of
distribution
and they're now going to left eyes all
of the means of distribution
of institutional power in our society
the greatest indicator of this of course
is that apparently on sunday there was a
meeting of more than 100
chief executives and corporate leaders
they gathered online sunday according to
the washington post to discuss taking
new action
to combat the controversial state voting
bills being considered across the
country
including one recently signed into law
in georgia so you now have
major corporations that have decided to
just do the work of the democratic party
and the reason they're doing the work of
the democratic party
is because they believe that the
democratic party is in an unbreakable
ascendancy right now
they believe that the country is moving
ever more leftward and that there is no
worry that there will be backlash from
the right
and so they are just going to do what
the democratic party wants them to do
and in return presumably the democratic
party will leave them alone a little bit
or grant them additional regulatory
power or give them tax breaks
or ensure in some other regulatory
fashion that their opponents are stifled
that's what's really going on here
because if you believe that all these
major corporations
gave two dams about georgia's voting law
which again does not really
does not restrict the right to vote it
does not voter id is not a restriction
on the right to vote
maintaining more ballot boxes than there
were in 2016 is not a restriction on the
right to vote
broadening voting hours in many counties
is not a restriction on the right to
vote
but these corporations know that they
have to just become the uh another wing
of the democratic party the privatized
wing of the democratic party or the
democrats are going to come after them
until they are caving on behalf of the
democrats this is extremely dangerous
stuff
there are tens of millions of americans
who work for these companies
i saw a chart over the weekend it showed
the political donations from employees
of america's biggest companies
nearly all a majority of those come a
majority of employees those companies
gave to democrats
so what we are watching is the complete
hijacking of corporate america on behalf
of the radical left and then you will
watch a cram down happen internally
inside these companies
and an attitude taken with regard to the
customer base that requires that you
exceed
to their politics this deeply dangerous
stuff
we'll get to more of this in just one
second first let us talk about the fact
now is not a great time to go over to
your local auto parts store because
why would you ever do that you're going
to stand in line eventually you'll get
to the front of the line when you
finally do get to the front of the line
they'll ask you for details that you
don't know and then they're just going
to order the partner online anyway
because they don't actually have it then
they upcharge you for it
so why would you do that instead why
don't you just cut out the middleman
and go straight to the interwebs my
friends at rockauto.com
will take care of you rockauto.com
always offers the lowest prices possible
rather than changing prices based on
what the market will bear like airlines
do why would you spend up to twice as
much
for the same parts rockauto.com is a
family business that serves auto parts
customers online
for 20 years go to rockauto.com right
now shop for auto and body parts from
hundreds of manufacturers best of all
prices at rockauto.com are always
reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers why
would you spend up to twice as much for
the same parts the rockauto.com catalog
is unique it is remarkably easy to
navigate you can quickly see all the
parts available for your vehicle
and you can choose the brands
specifications and prices you prefer
they've got amazing selection reliably
low prices all the parts your car will
ever need
rockauto.com head on over to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for your car or truck right
shapiro in there how did you care about
us box
so they know that we sent you that is
rockauto.com go check them out
right now okay so these corporations
have decided that they are going to just
shift into the democratic party playbook
and they're doing something different
than corporations have done in the past
corporations have always given money to
politicians
there's been a thing for a very very
long time in american politics and that
is not rare
nobody would be surprised to see the
heads of google give money to democrats
nobody be particularly surprised to see
the heads of walmart give money to
republicans right none of this
was particularly shocking what is
shocking is that corporate america is
now seeking to punish the voters
directly that is a different thing okay
so corporations deciding
that they want to give to this
politician or not give to that
politician
those are corporate political decisions
they've been going on for a long time
right they have lobbyists
those lobbyists have been working in
washington literally for
for at this point centuries in america
but
there's a different thing going on when
you have corporations that are openly
targeting the voting population
and attempting to bully them into voting
the way they want that is a different
thing entirely
it's amazing the same left that will
suggest that corporations are bullying
their own employees
for not pushing in favor of unionization
that's not bullying that is just a free
market exchange
those same people will be perfectly
happy with corporations
removing their business from places
simply based on the politics of those
places and how people voted in those
places
and they are ecstatic that mlb removed
the all-star game from atlanta georgia
because georgia
georgian voters decided that they were
going to vote in favor of republicans in
the state house
punishing the population is a very very
different thing than punishing
particular politicians nobody's saying
you have to give to republicans you want
to be a corporation and give to
democrats
so be it don't expect a lot of help from
republicans on the other end
right why would you but if you are if
you're a corporation and you are
targeting the voting base itself
that is a completely different thing
frankly this is a standard that we've
had
with our own advertisers here on shows
like this one now they're advertisers
who have decided they no longer want to
advertise with us
that's their prerogative but when you
target the people who listen to the show
when you say the people who listen to
the show are bad or their views are bad
and they're not doing business because
you don't like the views of the people
who listen to the show
well then you're on the other side a
business decision is not the same
as a political decision and these
corporations are jumping full skill into
making political decisions by attempting
to blackmail states
that is what they are doing right now
these are major corporations remember
these are the people who are in
institutional power these are not
outsiders attempting to stop
the march of fascism these are political
insiders extraordinarily connected
extraordinarily wealthy
this is not the masses who are
attempting to rise up against power this
is the powerful the voters of georgia
are significantly less powerful than the
heads of google and mlb
no question about it according to
jeffrey sonnenfeld a yale management
professor who organized the call
executives from major airlines retailers
and manufacturers plus at least one nfl
owner
talked about potential ways to show they
oppose the legislation including by
halting donations to politicians who
support the bills and even delaying
investments in states
that pass the restrictive measures now
again your prerogative you don't want to
give money to republicans again don't
expect that those republicans are then
going to rush to your defense when it
comes to
you proclaiming your allegiance to free
market principles because you don't give
it about free market principles
obviously you're backing the party that
stands against them
but by the same token very different
thing if you've decided you are
literally going to boycott those states
if you're going to boycott
those states now you have engaged in
political warfare upon your own consumer
base you've decided that people who
don't think like you
ought not consume your product fine you
believe that we will take you up on that
we'll 100 take you up on that and we'll
fight back as consumers we'll start our
own businesses
these are dangerous dangerous things and
by the way it seems to me perfectly
justified that in america in which
anti-discrimination law rules the roost
in which anti-discrimination law which
has been in the ascendancy in the united
states since the 1960s
for originally some good reasons and now
some very bad reasons
anti-discrimination law
which is rooted in the idea that freedom
of association is
must be curbed in the name of ability to
patronize
if you believe that then it seems to me
well within the realm of possibility
that states are simply going to start
adding
political orientation as a basis for
non-refusal of service
in states across the country that if
you're going to do business in georgia
you don't get to decide who you do
business with based on politics
otherwise you can just leave it seems
like that is the way that a lot of these
states are going to go i know that
discussion is being had at the highest
levels
in some of the red states you're seeing
right now because governors are not
going to allow
their their states to essentially become
the preserve
of corporations that wish to bludgeon
their constituencies into silence
according to the washington post while
no final steps are agreed upon the
meeting represents an aggressive dialing
up of corporate america's stand against
controversial voting measures nationwide
you think they give a damn about this
seriously these controversial voting
measures by the way again are less
restrictive than many
voting measures in states like delaware
for example these corporations didn't
care five seconds ago
but corporations are notoriously slow to
react and
quick to overreact so they are slow to
react to trends
then when they sense the trend they
react in radical
hammer fashion nothing is done with a
scalpel everything is done with a
chainsaw
and so instead of these corporations
being going to the republican
legislature in georgia and saying here
are the provisions that we don't like
this one and this one
instead of doing that they wait until
the law is passed and then they see that
stacey abrams is super pissed and then
they're like oh well if stacey abrams is
super pissed maybe we ought to just cut
off all business with the state of
georgia
this is not gonna work out well for you
guys it's not gonna work out well for
you guys because guess what
if you guys decide not to do business in
the state of georgia there are plenty of
other people who are more than happy to
do business in the state of georgia
the consumers don't go away the
businesses do all of this came just days
after senate minority leader mitch
mcconnell warned that firms should stay
out of politics
echoing a view shared by many
conservative politicians and setting up
the potential for additional conflict
between republican leaders and the heads
of some of america's largest firms
now again the media are playing this is
the republicans are the reactionary ones
nope the corporations are the
reactionary ones they're reacting to the
predations of the radical left and then
republicans are reacting to the fact
that all of these corporations have
decided to target their voters
by the way it's now coming out that
stacey abrams seems to be a liar
stacey abrams said that she had no
impact on mlb moving the game apparently
mlb spoke directly to stacey abrams
before they decided to move the all-star
game
leaders from dozens of companies delta
american united starbucks target
linkedin levi strauss boston consulting
group
along with the owner of the atlanta
falcons were included in the zoom call
we'll have more on this
in just one second because this is a
truly dangerous trend in american life
it's gonna lead to the breakup of the
country
okay so according to the washington post
the discussion
which was scheduled to last one hour but
went on for 10 minutes longer was led at
times by ken chennault the former chief
executive of american express and
kenneth frazier the chief executive of
merck who told the executives it was
important to keep fighting what they
viewed as discriminatory laws on voting
both chenelle and frazier are of course
black and they coordinated a letter
signed last month by 72 black business
executives that made a similar point
now all of this could stop if
corporations just said no that's the
amazing thing about this all
corporations have to do
is say listen we are not in the business
of signing
into debates over voter id and it's just
not in our purview
what's in our purview is how for example
the the government regulates corporate
earnings
what is within our purview this is part
of the other problem right so there's
two problems one
corporations have moved beyond simply
targeting politicians based on their
stances
and have decided to target overt
populations which is a big change the
other thing that has happened in
corporate america
is that corporate america has decided
and they are not going to restrict their
opinions
to areas in which the corporation
operates they're going to
now have opinions on everything it's
going to be like what does coca-cola
think about this this law in arkansas
that says the children
should not have medical experimentation
done on them for purposes of transgender
verification well i i mean their silence
is deafening
right well we have now reached the point
in corporate america we have reached the
taylor swift's silence's deafening point
in corporate america for those who are
not aware of this meme
for years taylor swift was fairly
apolitical and then everybody online
kept saying whenever there was a
controversial thing happening in
american politics
taylor swift's silence is deafening and
those of us on the right were like um
she makes music
why do you care about what taylor swift
has to say and then taylor swift
got hit so hard so much from the left
that she decided to go fully woke
and she started producing songs like 10
years later about gay rights
she turned into pop star never stopped
never stopping
right in that in that movie which is
very funny there's a there's a
andy sandberg plays a character who's
this pop star
and he makes this pro gay rights song
but he's like 20 years late on it
and so everybody's like why is he even
making this that was taylor swift she
makes this gay rights song
like 10 years after gay marriage becomes
a thing in the united states everybody's
like why should well it's pretty obvious
why she was doing it she was bullied
into it by the left
corporations are now the taylor swift of
our politics corporations have decided
that they are going to their silence is
deafening they must speak out on
everything the left demands of them okay
guys well if that's the way you want it
that's the way you're going to have it
if you're going to engage in the ultra
crepitarianism
speaking outside of your purview in
which you are not commenting anymore
about corporate tax rates
or the restrictions on sugar imports
from cuba button stick as coca-cola but
instead you are now going to comment
on bathroom bills in north carolina then
you are explicitly political actors and
you will be treated as such
and the consuming public will do so and
republican legislators will do so
and that is not reactionary on the on
the part of republicans that is not them
starting the fight
that is them simply saying if you guys
have chosen to engage in this field you
will be treated as somebody engaging in
this field you will be treated as an
adjunct to the democratic party which is
what you are
the cause goal according to the
washington post was to unify companies
that have been issuing their own
statements and signing on to drafted
statements from different organizations
after the action in georgia
sonnenfeld said the leaders called in
from around the country
some chimed in from augusta georgia
where they were attending the masters
yeah i noticed that rob manfred did not
in fact
the head of mlb did not in fact give up
his uh his membership to augusta
national
and i've noticed that coca-cola has not
moved its corporate headquarters i've
noticed that cnn by the way has not
moved its corporate headquarters which
is located in atlanta which means
presumably they endorse the georgia
voting law
that's the way this works right
sonnenfeld this professor from yale he
says
there is a defiance of the threats that
businesses should stay out of politics
they were obviously rejecting that even
with their presence on the call but they
were there out of concern about voting
restrictions not being in the public
interest yeah sure
or they were there because they know
they're getting blackmailed by the left
and they are deeply afraid that their
investment
pension funds union pension funds run by
the seiu
that are going to pull money from their
stock price well again
this game can work both ways this can
work both ways
if by the way these folks think that
that joining with corporate america is
going to gain you massive popularity
let me recommend that you take a look at
the republican party which joined with
corporate america in nearly every
iteration over the past 30 years and
proceeded to lose
massive amounts of power in the united
states it turns out that you know what
americans typically don't like big
corporations cramming down their views
and it's even worse when those big
corporations have decided to move out of
the realm of tax rates corporate tax
rates and have decided to move into the
realm of
what do we think your children should be
learning in school i do not give two
craps with kenneth chanel things my kids
should be learning in public school
i don't want to know what american
express thinks about this i have no
interest in them
and if they try to tell me what to do
i'm just not going to patronize their
business
i will take out a different credit card
and if all of the credit cards decide to
do this there will be regulations that
prohibit them from doing this in red
states
you can see how these corporations are
going to wield their executive power
in order to damage the american people
and you can see it most clearly in the
realm of social media
so for example this is the most obvious
and ridiculous example
over the weekend it broke that patrice
kullers who is 37
is and one of the founders of black
lives matter has now bought a 1.4
million dollar home
in topanga canyon now being from
california i can assure you topanga
canyon is super white
that is an extremely white area in fact
it is 88
white and 1.8 percent black so patrice
cooler as soon as she made some money
off of blm
she bought a nice house right there in
topanga canyon
apparently it is a it is a pretty
expensive house has a vast great room
with a vaulted and beamed ceiling
the realtors write that the large
backyard is ideal for entertaining or
quietly contemplating cross canyon
vistas
framed by mature trees the ap reported
that black lives matter took in 90
million dollars in donations last year
it's not clear if or how colors is paid
by the organizations its finances are
opaque which means of course the people
are taking out vast quantities of cash
whenever the finances of an organization
are opaque it can be pretty sure that
whoever is at the head of the
organization is doing pretty well
so patrice colors first opportunity she
immediately takes her 1.4 million
home in super white topanga canyon okay
so here is where this becomes
more than just a hilarious story of more
limousine liberal hypocrisy
okay that is jason whitlock who
is the black writer for the blaze now
jason whitlock he apparently was
he was apparently barred from twitter
for tweeting out the story
apparently they locked his account right
he tweeted out black lives matter
founder buys 1.4 million home
1.4 million home in tapanga which has a
black population of 1.4 percent
she's with her people and this got jason
whitlock's account locked
it got his account locked because that's
the way all of this works now is if you
violate
what corporate america would like for
you to say there's a good shot
that you're going to be targeted by
corporate america
you can see this happening also by the
way in terms of covid
because the entire left now has an
interest in pushing coveted panic porn
which we'll get to in just one second
but youtube as we mentioned
last week pulled a covered round table
with governor florida
with florida governor ron desantis saron
desantis had scott ellis and j
batacharya from stanford and a couple
other scientists on a panel
and on that panel members of the panel
said that small children should not be
wearing masks a waste of time
okay that is at least a debatable
opinion that is certainly not well
established that five-year-olds need to
be wearing masks they are not good at
wearing masks
there's a good case that they do not
transmit the disease in anything like
the numbers that adults transmit the
disease
that when they do transmit the disease
it tends to be a weaker strain
of the disease apparently because
they're they're
sort of the the the disease counts is
just not as high uh the germ count is
not as high
okay so that is a very reasonable
reasonable and debatable opinion youtube
pulled the entire video because this of
course contradicted
the nature of the stuff that youtube
wants to put out there about covet
all of which prompted jay bhattacharya
an epidemiologist from stanford mind you
to say this is crazy i'd love to have a
debate with somebody at youtube because
apparently
some low-level dope at youtube believes
they know more about epidemiology than
botocharia does
i mean it's really it's really crazy it
really it's it's one of these things
where you look at it and you say
how can we how can you have an open
discussion about a policy that affects
every single person's life when you
can't actually even have it
have a make up make a point based on
scientific
evidence uh it's really and it makes you
they you know they want to make you
think
that the only way forward is these
lockdowns but we can see that they've
failed
let's have that debate bhattacharya is
right about this but again it's
corporate america's power that is
allowing them particularly in the social
media sphere where they are in the free
speech sphere
to just shut down alternative methods of
debate and this becomes particularly
relevant when you see
neutral service providers like amazon
web services shutting down parlor at the
beginning of the year
simply because they said based on a lie
the power lord was the chief
organizing mechanism used in order to
organize the january sixth riots
okay the the chief organizing mechanisms
by all available evidence were facebook
and twitter
it was discussed apparently on parlor
but apparently more of the discussion
was happening on facebook and twitter
you didn't see those guys getting pulled
down by amazon web services
but again contravene what corporate
america wants you to know about
particular issues or what corporate
america wants you to think about
particular issues and they will use
every means at their disposal in order
to come after you
this is deeply dangerous stuff and they
are in fact promoting lie after lie
about america
america being systemically racist the
new jim crow in georgia
and kovitz still on the loose we're
going to talk about the coveted panic
porn in just one second because
it's beyond the pale at this point first
let us talk about the fact
that when i am in public i always have
to be on the ready to defend myself
my family you do too i mean you always
want to be ready to defend yourself
and defend your family and that is why i
highly recommend it taser taser's line
of non-lethal self-protection devices
they're small they're lightweight enough
to carry with you
or in your glove compartment or in your
purse my wife has one there's a good
reason for it they're powerful enough to
incapacitate an attacker they use an
electrical charge to immobilize
attackers for up to 30 seconds
giving you time to escape to safety and
they send emergency dispatch to your gps
location
they also have laser assisted targeting
you can protect yourself and your family
with taser's line
of smart self-defense products i love
the fact that my wife is now protected
it means i worry less about her and she
worries less about herself she can
defend herself now
using non-deadly force for a limited
time take advantage of taser's best
offer available save 60 bucks on the
pulse
plus bundle with a taser pulse plus
device cartridges and holster at
taser.com
save 60 right now by using code ben
right now at taser.com
that's t-a-s-e-r.com taser.com protect
yourself protect your family
do it in non-lethal fashion it's a
fantastic device go check them out right
now
taser.com save 60 bucks right now by
using
codebend when you go to taser.com
alrighty we'll get to more in just a
second about the media's panic porn
again they are shutting down debate on
issues that are very debatable
first it's already episode five and
people just can't get enough of candace
owns or new show candace if you haven't
checked it out yet i don't know what
you're waiting for the fearless thought
leader hosts a lively series of guests
every week for a discussion panel
interviews and her signature cancel
corner that's my favorite part of the
show this week she'll be hosting
comedian and podcaster adam corolla
tune in you're not going to want to miss
their conversation the show streams on
fridays at 9 00 pm eastern 8 pm central
at dailywire.com
you can get the audio podcast canvas on
apple spotify or wherever you listen to
your podcast so
if you need some candace owns in your
podcast feed look no further head on
over to apple podcast or spotify
subscribe today be sure to leave a five
star review if you like
what you hear you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
the amount of panic porn that is now
being pushed on you by the media is
truly astonishing i was noting this over
the weekend so
people it's amazing youtube will pull
down pull down
a reasonable conversation among
scientists about whether or not small
children need to wear masks
or whether they ever needed to wear
masks they'll pull that down over at
youtube but you can say the most insane
crap about vaccines and their
ineffective and their ineffectiveness
and that apparently is fine so long as
you're on the left so for example joy
reid over the weekend
tweeted out that she was with jonathan k
part she said i too am one backs down
but even when i get the second shot
i'm too scared to be out there wilden no
flying and no indoor activities for me
nope hashtag the sunday show okay this
is vaccine to nihilism
right here you wanna talk about
denialism this is denialism
the vaccines are extraordinary they're
one of the great scientific
accomplishments
of the last several centuries do you
have a vaccine inside of a year
that is 99 effective at preventing
serious disease and death
it's a miracle the notion that you are
still not going to be flying by the way
the evidence that this was transmitted
on flights is non-existent there is no
evidence
at all literally none since the
beginning of the pandemic
that airline flights were a chief source
of transmission for the virus
hey there again there are great hepa
filters on the planes
there's there's really not a lot when i
say not a lot of it i'm not aware of a
single study
that says that airplanes were achieved
vector of transmission throughout this
pandemic
and not that you can't catch on you can
catch it on an airplane but that they
were a chief transmission vector
or a key transmission no okay there's no
evidence of that as far as i'm aware
whatsoever not only that once you get
the vaccine
what in the world are you talking about
the vaccine is super duper effective
like incredibly effective
but apparently that's where denialism is
not only okay it is welcomed on the left
that after you've had the vaccine you
still won't go out you still won't
engage in society which of course
necessitates the government step in and
take care of you
if everybody followed joy reads advice
we'd all be stuck in our homes forever
and the government would just keep
signing us checks based on cash that
does not exist
so that is simple vaccine denialism and
it's being taken up by the horrible
media coverage
our media are so garbage at this i mean
unbelievably garbage with their coverage
so for example cnn put out a story
that is totally wrong about how to fly
safely a year into the pandemic now
here's the thing
you could fly safely throughout the
pandemic you could if you wore a mask
and you were on a plane you were pretty
much okay
again the the there is no i'm not aware
of any surge of documented cases
that began on an airplane you can say
that people traveled with coveted on the
other end of the airplane they spread it
when they got into an apartment building
or something but that's not the same
thing as saying the airplanes with the
chief vector of transmission okay put
that aside
here's what cnn says and this is just
statistically illiterate
they said real world studies of the
pfizer bioentech and modern vaccines
show they are only 90 protective against
covid not 95
as reported in clinical trials
translated into reality that means for
every million fully vaccinated people
who fly
some 100 000 could still become infected
no rongo that is statistically
illiterate
so first of all when they say they're 90
protective against coronavirus
that means they are 90 protective
against getting coronavirus
okay that does not mean they are only 90
effective in preventing death or serious
disease from coronavirus that's still at
99 to 100
okay beyond that that's not how
statistics work okay if there are a
million people
who fly on planes and there's a vaccine
that are taken
by everybody right everybody has taken
the vaccine but it's only 90
effective in preventing the transmission
of the disease that doesn't mean
that there are a hundred thousand people
who are going to get the disease
okay as national review points out
translated into actual reality a 90
effective vaccine refers to a reduction
in the odds of a vaccinated person
being infected relative to somebody who
has not taken the vaccine
that is in a given group of say 2 000
people if 100 unvaccinated people would
ordinarily get coveted just 10
vaccinated just 10 vaccinated people and
the same size group would get the virus
that does not mean that 200 vaccinated
people would get the virus
right in other words you have to have
what's called a base rate okay if there
are a million people who fly on planes
and a hundred thousand people are not
protected against the virus it doesn't
mean all a hundred thousand people get
coveted that's never been true the hell
are you talking about
a tiny percentage of those people will
get covered and then of those people
90 percent will not get covered if
they're vaccinated that's what that stat
means so instead
cnn is openly panicking you that if you
fly and you're vaccinated you're still
going to get covered
you wonder why with media coverage like
that people are still worried they're
gonna get coveted after being vaccinated
okay another piece
of of news that the media are blowing
way the hell out of proportion
if you look at drudge today which has
just become huffington post
okay drudge has a headline at the top of
its page in all red
pfizer can't stop south african strain
now if you read that headline what would
you think
what would i think so i've had the
pfizer vaccine at this point okay so
what would i what would i think i would
think okay well that means that if the
south african strain hits me i'm screwed
right pfizer can't stop the south
african strain wrong
okay that is not what the story says
what the story says
is quote the south african variant of
the coronavirus is notably more adept at
breaking through the pfizer biointect
vaccine than other variants are
israel has used the pfizer vaccine
almost exclusively to vaccinate millions
of citizens with a version by moderna
using used minimally a team from tel
aviv university and the klalit
healthcare organization sequenced the
swabs of 150 israelis who tested
positive for coven 19 despite having
been vaccinated
okay so there are 150 israelis who
tested positive for covet after having
been vaccinated
six to seven million people in israel
have already been vaccinated
so number one you're already talking
about pretty much
statistically almost nobody who got the
virus after having
been vaccinated then in that subgroup
what did they find that subgroup of 150
israelis tested positive for cova 19
after having being vaccinated here's
what they found in their study the
prevalence of the south african strain
among vaccinated individuals who were
infected
despite their inoculation was eight
times higher than its prevalence in the
uninfected
that in the unvaccinated infected
population
though the number of infections among
the vaccinated was relatively small
the findings indicated that this variant
was far more successful than getting
through vaccinated individuals defenses
than other strains so number one
when we say relatively small we are
talking about nearly everyone
in israel got the pfizer vaccine you
have like
150 200 people who actually got infected
afterward and your takeaway from that is
that the pfizer vaccine
is not protective against south african
strains
you're talking about a margin at the
very very very tip top right here
you're talking about a tiny group of
people got infected after the vaccine
and of that tiny group of people more
people were infected with south african
strain
also not noted in the study did any of
those people get super sick and die
nope so it turns out that pfizer is
still extraordinarily effective against
all of the strains in fact in lab tests
pfizer has been proved to be effective
against the south african strain
according to dr marti mccary of johns
hopkins university
so like no that's ridiculous if your
takeaway is that you got a pfizer
vaccine and now you're going to die
of the of the south african variant no
wrong okay but that is the takeaway from
the media this is all panic porn you
know who's been pushing that panic porn
naturally dr anthony fauci fouch is
pushing the panic porn
over the weekend fauci said that he
would still not do a lot of things after
getting the vaccine
right he still said that he would host
people at home but stay away from
crowded indoor spaces
after getting the vaccine he said i
don't think i would even if i'm
vaccinated go into an indoor crowded
place where people are not wearing masks
why explain explain doctor really
explain
it's 99 to 100 effective against death
or serious disease so now what you are
saying is that
if you are afraid of getting a mild
disease you should stay away from public
places
my god he said we shouldn't claim
victory over the virus yet because case
counts
are surging in several states okay
again i'm gonna look at the case council
right now
okay i'm gonna bring up the case counts
right now right now case counts in the
united states
are in fact not surging they are not
searching
okay over the april 10th there were 67
000 diagnosed cases of covid in the
united states that was april 10th
february 23rd there were 74 000 cases
diagnosed
we are not surging we are completely
flat in the numbers of diagnosed cases
in the united states and in terms of
daily new deaths we are at the lowest
point
that we were since at this point
looks like september october of last
year when people thought maybe we were
already hitting the end of this thing
so his takeaway is just nonsense but
they're trying to scare the hell out of
you and then
they're trying to bully you into silence
if you're not scared the goal here is to
scare the hell out of you so then they
can overreach as much as they could
possibly want
by the way how crazy are they getting
about all of this how nuts okay they are
getting so nuts about all of this then
now
they've decided that they are targeting
amy chua the famous professor over at
yale
law school so apparently she was having
little gatherings at her home where she
was meeting with students who were
having trouble
and people decided that she had to be
covered policed
she writes a letter says i received an
email from a yale daily news reporter
named julia brown who informed me she
was working on our in
an article about how you will not be
leading a small group at the law school
next year and that there will likely be
a formal announcement about it on monday
this is the first i'd heard about it the
reporter's email implied that the
decision had been made on the basis of
an allegation
that i've been recently hosting parties
at my house ridiculous allegations i'd
never heard for
before from anyone finally the email
contained a shocking number of
confidential agreements
details about an agreement i reached
back in 2019 which the daily news was
apparently preparing to publish
and um and apparently this then went
public and they're trying to
basically kick her out of these small
group sessions
because she was hosting small groups of
people at her home
who'd been vaccinated i'm sorry
we are now living in the in the middle
of a major corporate crackdown
on free speech the institutions of power
have decided
that they no longer need your opinion
instead they are going to be shaping
your opinion from above
and they're going to be doing so on the
basis of their own self-satisfied
sense of who they are and they're going
to be cheering on the biden
administration as they do the same
so if you don't want that it is past
time to fight back on all of this
because you simply cannot trust the
corporate media
you can't trust your corporate leaders
there are no institutions standing
between you
and the naked face of an authoritarian
left that seeks to cram down its values
on you and against you which means
number one got to build their own
institutions and number two have to
fight back against the institutions that
currently prevail already we'll be
back here later today with an additional
hour of content in the meantime
go check out the michael knowles show
where he discusses how brian stelter
wants to watch conservatives get the
vaccine yeah that was a weird thing
for those who missed it on cnn brian
stelter said it was really bad that
that hosted fox news hadn't taken
selfies getting the vaccine super super
bad
meanwhile joyride is out there saying
things like even after i get the vaccine
i'm not going to go out in public ever
again
you near more details about that story
over on michael's show that's available
right now i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
morin
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavel wydowski
editing is by adam sciavitz audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant is jessica crans
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
brian stelter wants to watch
conservatives get the covid vaccine
pete boudijedge says the roads are
racist and a public university demands
that students adopt the woke religion
check it out
on the michael knowles show
you